ne vous êtes-vous jamais demandé comment
cette bourde a été fabriqué bonne
question n'est ce pas je me suis aussi
dit un jour que j'étais un très mauvais
orateur internet c'est génial parce
qu'internet permet d'avoir une réponse à
n'importe quelle question que tu peux te
poser comme ça au fil du temps je me
suis mis à avoir une petite frustration
genre mais attend comment ce micro et
fabriqué par exemple quand comment on en
arrive à avoir ce micro avoir un truc
qui prend le son et y'a des trucs encore
plus bas taux genre quand tu bois une
boisson intéresse dans une bouteille en
verre commencé douter revers a été
fabriqué dites moi que j'ai pas à
écouter sur le net
y'a genre masse vidéo qui te montre en
très peu de temps genre deux minutes
comment sont fabriqués des objets du
quotidien et à des surprises de ouf
c'est pas du tout évident c'est même
très très dur de deviner en fait quand
tu connais pas bref commencions avec le
plus célèbre comment est fabriqué un
vinyle
on dirai clairement une pâte à pizza
hockey qu'on met dans des granulés avant
de la mettre sur un disque avec ses
petits grains du lion dire un bonbon sur
vidic mais n'en dira un bonbon il ya une
presse qui se fait satisfaisant
satisfaisant très satisfaisant on coupe
la petite patte qui dépasse on a le
dessus du attend quoi c'est fini fini
mais la partie noire qu'on met face à la
machine à on y vient
non non mais attendez là ils ont fait le
dessus du vinyle pas de sous non mais là
ya pas de musique sur ce disque c'est
que la partie du dessus j'ai rien
compris
cette vidéo qui explique jaleh a compris
comment sont fabriqués des lego ça c'est
intéressant puisque c'est plein plein
plein de petites pièces dans des
quantités énormes donc la chaîne de
production il doit être assez ouf à voir
au pire un cimetière de bonhomme légaux
oh non on dirait un film de science
fiction qui assemble des robots dans le
but de décimé l'humanité
c'est exactement 16 incroyable les
imprime les visages c'est vraiment une
scène d'un film de science-fiction
catastrophe où les robots ont pris le
dessus et y construisent d'android pour
décimé l'humanité
les lego ils sont méchants en fait c'est
hypnotisant je trouve ça crie pis ça m'a
vraiment fait peur aux quais commencent
on fait des ballons de baudruche
j'en ai pas la moindre idée ok mais tu
la couleur qu'ils veulent dans du latex
liquide et ensuite je suppose qu'un truc
de la forme du ballon va être imprégné
de latex hu
oui le latex va faire le tour et c'est
comme ça ok c'est logique j'ai whaou à
tence à ces gens un truc pour que le
texte puisse décoller je crois je sais
que des suppositions que je fais
d'accord y'a rien de concret vous
regardez ces vidéos pour avoir des
réponses vous en aurez aucune hockey
ensuite il et plonge dans le latex
coloré satisfaisant satisfaisant aux
[ __ ] de merde
oh c'est comme ça que qui tombent ou
effet au c'est incroyable vous l'aviez
pas celle là haut ça le rend encore plus
mignon ce petit embout ok là il les met
dans de l'eau chaude à l eau chaude
permet de retirer une protéine qui a
dans le latex responsables des allergies
de certains en fait au latex intéressant
à savoir c'est vrai que quand tu fais du
make-up des fois ils mettent des pièges
savez pour faire les make up très poussé
tout genre une joue gros fléau en deuil
cabossé poisse pas du tout bon adjectif
bah en fait c'est du latex compte mais
qu'ensuite on maquille et du coup tu as
besoin de ces de la peau bah moi j'ai
fait une allergie à ça dans cette vidéo
la de merde
l'érection de vidéos pardon sponsorisés
comme toutes les biopsies prague hemming
à l'époque oui contrairement à cette
vidéo là où le ballon pourtant fait de
la même matière que les prothèses ne
m'avait pas du tout brûler voilà au
moins ils sont gonflés aux salles éjecte
ses trophées et ensuite ça le fait
tomber sur un tapis et c'est sa fille
dans l'emballage supposée à ils émettent
à la machine à laver avant hockey [ __ ]
mais que la prochaine fois que je vais
gonfler un ballon arrive je vais qui
fait des ouf j'ai pour assortir cette
fameuse phrase d'amiens je sais comment
c'est faire un ballon de baudruche qua
non est vraiment j'ai pas envie de ça en
fait y'a des moules et ya du latex
liquide et du coup on vraiment tu
deviens le tonton chiant des bouteilles
en verre or les fameuses haye et
l'histoire de mon matière en fusion
avant que ça donne du verre bien
évidemment je suppose c'est un système
de moules comme pour
les ballons de baudruche sauf que là
c'est de la matière en fusion et si tu
sais le seigneur des anneaux sa découpe
le truc quoi est il est mitraillée il
parle sous forme de mitraillettes
croyez moi c'est vraiment beau ya un
vrai côté beau quoi voilà tout est faux
et abus dans une bouteille en verre est
ce que vous saviez que c'était comme ça
et bah non je sais pas si j'essaie de me
prouver là on vous dispense à mais c'est
pas ouf [ __ ] ya une machine qui polit
l'extrémité pour qu'elles soient hyper
lycée que quand elle tue puisse boire de
dents sont écorchés quoi c'est dingue
tous ces petits détails le cerveau des
mecs des ingénieurs à la qui ont
conceptualisé toute cette chaîne de
production ça me dépasse
des valises pas hyper intéressant
premier abord mais je suis sûr qu'on va
être surpris à temps il s'est passé quoi
là mais attends mais quoi pourquoi c'est
gonflé d'un coup ça se rabat sur tous
les coins mais chut j'ai fait ça me
surprend encore plus que la fois d'avant
des élastiques
ça doit être un truc de matières
liquides qui devient solide et je suis
en train de faire semblant
j'en ai aucune idée ok c'est que ça
c'est que j'ai fait le ravioli 10
aplatissent peu à peu en une couche de
plus en plus fine du soufre
j'ai envie de sauter dedans j'utilise
très peu d'élastiques pour atteinte avec
vous mais dingue je vais faire pipi
c'est une grande première je crois en
plein visage au clairement et c'est un
pipi et comment sont faits les toilettes
tiens comment les toilettes sont faits
oh mais on dirait que je suis sur écoute
ou koala google vous m'écoutez oh là là
bas c'est en porcelaine souvent les
toilettes non [ __ ] je dis que de la
verbe haut
donc on a des moules à à des moules à
chiottes en fait hockey qu'on remplit
d'une certaine matière ensuite on retire
le moule qua non mais là c'est des
chiottes de luxe non pour que soit fait
main comme ça non je rêve ou c'est
toujours comme ça ok c'est vraiment de
la poterie mais masterisé quoi c'est des
chiottes que j'aurais dû faire dans ma
vidéo poterie ensuite y met une matière
il lave je vais a compris comment s'est
passée de marrons à blanc par contre
j'ai pas j'ai pas capté hockey ensuite
il lui il hume et 3g dans la gueule à la
toilette
c'est tellement débile et bien péter la
toilette à parce qu'il l'avait pas cuit
et on sait une fois qu'elle est cuit ça
donne ça ok war bah écoutez je vais un
peu plus appréciés à l'auto allait
dorénavant comment les chips sont faites
ça se passe compliquée si
quoi c'est un bandeau de chips hockey
auquel on a tapé la forme de la chips et
ensuite ça passe au four et dans l'huile
waouh c'est dingue
on est très très loin du coup deux
tranches de pommes de terre quoi hockey
ensuite ça rend dans les paquets comme
ça ok intéressant je savais pas que
c'était des rouleaux de pâte quoi à la
base dans lequel on venait taper la
forme de la chaise ou en vrai si c'est
assez logique en fin de compte c'est si
c'est mon cauchemar
c'est une usine à poupet c'est mon
cauchemar
[Musique]
je trouve déjà sacrifié le matin c'était
super coupe et fait mal à assas et
pourtant du célèbre
un étendoir à tête de poupée pas mal
flow frictionne drilling
ouf assez bon en fait soul décade du
métal et de la matière à très haute
température c'est vraiment beau quoi
waouh c'est une perceuse à métaux pour
faire des trous dans le métal
du coup en fait ça fait augmenter le
doubs où la température du métal et du
coup il se déforme et tu peux faire ton
tous ces beaux si on n'a qu'à bien peu
ce truc de métal etc
il ya des vidéos sur youtube d'artisans
qui fabrique des bagues et à certaines
vidéos comme ça d'ailleurs qui sont
super belle super bien monté et tout il
ya un truc très poétique voilà six ans
d'acquis qui tapait jewellery bas
démerdez-vous en fait c'est facile à
trouver comment les bretzels sont
fabriqués à j'avais vu voilà ils ont en
gros ils ont un stick de pâtes et de la
flore du bretzel ensuite il part en
cuisson quoi et tout le monde s'en bat
les couilles parce qu'en france personne
ne mange de bretzel comment un spa
jacuzzi et fabriqué au bas c'est vrai
que moi je me suis toujours demandé
comment mon spa jacuzzi été fabriqué
cette vidéo ça intéressait 10 personnes
ça va intéresser tam et ça c'est beau la
ce changement de matière
ouah non mais là c'est de la haute
ingénierie en fait c'est vraiment en
fait ce qui est intéressant en renvoyant
le processus de fabrication c'est que tu
comprend le coût de certaines choses
genre là ça ça doit coûter une blinde
une blinde le jacuzzi et tu comprends
pourquoi en fait en voyant les étapes de
fabrication fabrication d'une mini
poterie non mais ça vous m'envoyez
depuis la vidéo là tous les jours
certains m'envoie des vidéos comme ça
dans ce cas où des gars font des eaux
par un petit vase trop mignon trop
mignon regarder trop parfait encore plus
dur à faire carburer vaste puisqu'il
faut être minutieux mais ça c'est très
satisfaisant il ya un jeu mobile de
poterie j'ai eu des pubs après avoir
fait cette vidéo c'est le plaisir de
faire la poterie mais sans la
satisfaction d'avoir un objet à
l'arrivée que tu mets sur mon étagère
attend quoi c'est comment sont triés les
tomates quoi il ya des capteurs et des
trucs éjecte uniquement les tomates
vertes pas mûres à cette vitesse il
s'accroche on sous estime la technologie
qui nous entoure en vrai au le parfum à
intéressant de ouf
en 1967 donc ça a dû beaucoup changer
mais il m'était vraiment plein de
plantes
ça faisait un gros bloc de plans à au
kef ont infusé des deux lots du coup
dans ce cylindre dans lequel il ya
toutes les plantes j'aurais adoré faire
ça ça j'ai toujours kiffé à tout ce qui
est au deuil je me fous pas de votre
gueule on dit vous allez je me fous de
votre gueule d'un an vraiment j'ai
toujours adoré ce truc d'odeurs et de
chimie pour avoir une odeur
satisfaisante que certains vont adorer
que d'autres vont détester c'est
vraiment les goûts et les couleurs
j'aurais kiffé bosser dans ce truc là de
créer des secret l'odeur parfaite
je me fous pas google sur dur à là c'est
intéressant
faire de la fibre de polyester depuis
des bouteilles en plastique usagées
contrairement au coton qui est une
matière végétale le polyester c'est une
matière chimique c'est du plastique en
fait donc on a nos bouteilles en
plastique ah ouais vraiment ajax quoi il
mettra dans une machine qui leur donne
sorte de copeaux
moi et ça envoie de la fibre et c'est
comme ça qu'a du polyester jeu qu'on va
pourquoi on fait pas ça avec tout le
plastique horrible toutes les bouteilles
en plastique horrible qui circulent
encore plus quand on fait pas une chaîne
de recyclage basée sur ça en fait on en
a probablement mes jeux qu'on fait aussi
beaucoup si envoyer nos déchets à
l'étranger et payer un chèque et ça
pourrit en plein air et ça se déverse
naturel c'est l'enfer là c'est génial on
trouve un procédé pour transformer ces
déchets en tee shirt
mais c'est pas assez popularisé sur
serrières bon bref ça me dépasse mois
mais les gars le combo et l'incroyable
vous n'êtes pas prêt presse hydraulique
donc à la vidéo que de ça sur youtube un
degas qui écrase tout avec une presse
hydraulique ça fait tellement de vue
c'est satisfaisant à regarder plus le
gros métal rouge en fusion
world of warcraft
c'est le premier mot qui m'est venu à
l'esprit
c'est la plus belle chose mais c'est
exquis la carapace qui se cassent et
ensuite l'espèce de friction qui a
partout c'est incroyable fait un objet
de décoration qui reproduit sa double eh
bien écoutez je suis ravi de mieux
connaître le monde qui m'entoure
blaga page mais ça vous a plu je trouve
ça vraiment intéressant mais je trouve
ça fou le paradoxe entre à quel point
j'utilise certains objets et à quel
point j'ignore comment ils sont
fabriqués je trouve ça fâche tout c'est
ouf comme on est déconnecté de des
décennies d'évolution qui a eu des
siècles même avant de nous en fait on
est entouré tellement de choses
tellement technologie on peut pas tout
comprendre mais savoir comment est
fabriqué je sais pas moi du savon ou un
micro la capsule d'un micro fin je sais
pas il ya des trucs comme ça toi je me
dis [ __ ] j'ai envie de savoir
bref j'espère vous avez le même de lurs
ne vous avez passé une très mauvaise
vidéo on se dit à bientôt porter ou bien
le savoir regardez
ciao tout le monde
[Musique]